[Music]
when I saw him he was like I was seeing
a ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
how'd he start you hunting birds rabbit
I'm guessing 19 20 years old the first
time he ordered you to shoot a person
25 years ago he took my blood he made
you from me
he's been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you
[Applause]
he made a choice to do this to me the
whole point of this thing was to give
you all of Henry's gifts without his
pain I don't wanna shoot you mind if I
shoot you and raise this ever having you
before your own government trying to
kill you
that's new everything that we've worked
for is at stake
[Music]
he has to die is your darkness you had
to walk through this on your own I love
you Junior
we created
you're the inspiration for all of us
when I just make a whole army full of
them why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually knew
what we really are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop right there
who are you I don't want to shoot you
fine don't shoot me
mind if I shoot you did they show you a
picture of me yeah the whole
okay you take one step closer you gonna
leave me no choice
just trying to rattle me I'm trying to
save you
what are you 23
okay
[Music]
[Music]
25 years ago your father took my blood
and he cloned me he made you from me he
chose me because there's never been
anybody like me and one day I was going
to get old and then you'd step in he's
been lying to you the whole time he told
you you were an orphan and of all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you because I'm the best
you are obviously not the best he's your
clone how's that even possible in Gemini
man Aang is creating a visual spectacle
and the technology is so spectacular we
have a digital human being that will is
actually plane that's identical to what
you would expect a young Will Smith to
look like angrily believes that we gotta
push filmmaking into the 21st century I
was able to build on my past experience
in Life of Pi and what I think that
digital cinema should be doing which is
make it look more real more immersive
more humans
and has a very strong vision for this
film or shooting in 3d plus this
evolutionary format where see so much
more in a frame you really feel like
you're there
see detail of the fights of detailed
emotion that would be buried and blur at
a normal film format I kept on saying
that we all have to raise our game
because they are creating a digital
human we're putting a living breathing
young Will Smith into the frame it means
that you will have the most immersive
cinema experience that you've ever had
it's amazing to work with him he's such
a visionary as an amazing director he's
an Academy Award winner he's summit it's
always broken the boundaries of visual
effects Aang is pushing really hard to
give people an experience that you can't
get anywhere else I think I know why as
good as you is you what is so special
about Gemini man is at the center of it
you have two characters played by one
person across generations you're looking
at will he's looking at his younger self
that's a phenomenal experience for an
audience I play both 50 year old Henry
and 23 year old junior who's Santu
killer
the concepts of men being chased by
himself that's a really compelling idea
for a story thanks to the technology now
is possible
creating a digital human is one of the
hardest things you can do in visual
effects this is not D aging this does
not face replacement but what you see it
for jr. is a completely digital creation
100% driven by Wilson s performance
capture his performances his emotion
it's his ability as an actor to create
this really rich performance and then
play off of himself
I couldn't have played junior at 23
years old but now I'm able to understand
and capture both characters because of
the amount of experience that I've had
as an actor the technology were
inventing is something Angers been
wanting to do for a long time he's
making a leap forward and no other
director has even tried to do when you
see the two Will Smith so that's
something we're never experienced before
this technology is going to change how
movies are made and how movies are seen
[Music]
tell me something why is it so hard for
you to kill this man
he knew every move of mine before I made
it
[Music]
but have them right there take the shot
and he'd be gone like a ghost do you
really wanna
who is he
[Music]
I think I know why is as good as you
he is you 25 years ago they made you
from me they chose me because there's
never been anybody like me we have to
end this right now
you have all of his gifts without his
pain
you made a person out of another person
then you sent me to kill him
you made a choice to do this to me this
thing to your struggle what is fear
embrace them and then overcome it
of all the people in the world to come
after me why would he send you
[Music]